you're angry
sometimes anger makes people do
unfortunate things sometimes fear makes
them do unfortunate things I'll go with
anger
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight discussion video there are a few
things I want to clarify before I get
started with today's topic this video
isn't necessarily a prediction of mine
but what I wanted to do is talk about
some of the foreshadowing for Sansa
Starks death almost all of the evidence
I want to show you is from the book so
this might not have anything to do at
Game of Thrones Season eight but even if
you haven't read the books that doesn't
really matter because I'm not gonna be
diving too deep into them today anyway
but I just wanted to make that clear
because what happens in the future books
may not take place in the show but I'm
sure most of you know that by now but
let's get started
personally I'm not entirely sure if
someone's a stork will die but I do
think it's very possible because there
are a few signs of foreshadowing about
her death but like most things it's open
for interpretation I will go over a few
of them with you in this video then at
the end of the video just leave your
thoughts in the comment section and let
me know what you think about them now I
know this may sound blasphemous to some
of you but there are a few signs in the
books that point toward Arya Stark
killing her own sister Songza Stark it
doesn't mean it will happen but I do
think it's worth talking about at the
least the first thing I want to talk
about is songs of Starks dire wolf lady
as we all know Sansa Starks dire wolf
was the first one to die in the show and
it pretty much happened the same way in
the books the only big difference was
Ned Stark used his Valyrian steel sword
ice to kill lady in the books but in the
show he just used a small blade but the
reason why I'm even bringing this up is
because of the obvious connection each
Stark has with their dire wolves each of
them sort of represent their masters
personality and even their fate they
have a deeper and more spiritual
connection with each other and the names
of the dire wolves are symbolic in terms
of how their owner's stories can play
out at the beginning of this story songs
a stork wanted nothing more than to be a
lady or even a queen she certainly
played the part very well she looked
like a lady she talked like a lady and
she even walked like a lady she wanted
to be Joffrey's lady or Queen so bad she
was willing to betray her own family but
this fairy tale refers quickly started
to fade after Joffrey was attacked by
Orias dire wolf
Nymeria this is when Songza saw
firsthand just how ugly Joffrey and
Cersei could be Cersei immediately
demanded punishment she wanted the
direwolf to be killed but Arya made sure
nough mariya was not around the face to
music so Songz's dire wolf lady had to
be punished instead all their lady had
nothing to do with him this was when Ned
Stark decided he would do it himself
instead of having that animal sir Ilyn
Payne kill her now some would say when
Ned Stark killed lady this was the death
of Songz's own identity this was when
Songza realized that she wasn't going to
be living in any type of fairy tale what
the Prince Joffrey and I actually do
think that is true that is a fair way to
look at the situation but I think it
could also mean more than just that
before this happened Arya and Sansa were
already not very fond of each other but
this is when their relationship really
started to split Sansa was not happy
that lady had to die when Nymeria was
the one who bit Joffrey and that's
completely understandable but Zhaan's he
even went as far as telling Oriya that
she should have died instead of lady but
think about how Songz's direwolf lady
was actually killed lady was killed by
the hands of a stark and if Shaun's his
fate is parallel to her direwolves faith
and this could mean Sansa will die by
the hands of a stark as well but there
is another scene that could be
foreshadowing also and it may be a
little bit more direct than that this
happens very early on in the show in the
books this is shortly after Ned and his
daughter settle in the King's Landing
Ned finds Arya in her bedchamber and
this is when Ned sees arias sword needle
for the first time Ned takes the sword
and he inspects it and he asks where she
got it but he eventually gives it back
to Arya and he allows her to keep the
sword but first he says try not to stab
your sister with it now that could just
be seen as a throwaway line because the
Stork sisters were bickering with each
other at the time but it could also
foreshadow a very dark path or EO will
eventually take in the later books in
speaking of the books there is something
else I want to show you that could be
hinting at a deadly feud between Arya
and Sansa the first time I read these
few paragraphs it really jumped out at
me and maybe I am reading too much into
this
but you be the judge in the second book
Clash of Kings Sansa has a dream that is
very troubling and I think it says a lot
let me read it to you then I will point
out a few things that I think could
connect to her sister Arya Stark that
night Sean's a dreamed of the riot again
the mob surged around her shrieking a
maddening beast with a thousand faces
everywhere she turns she saw faces
twisted into monstrous inhuman masks she
wept and told them she had never done
them hurt yet they dragged her from her
horse all the same no she cried no
please don't don't but no one paid her
and he heed she shouted for sir Dontos
four brothers for her dead father and
her dead wolf for glance or lures who
had given her a red rose once but none
of them came she called for the heroes
from the songs for Florian in suraíh am
red wine and Prince a mon the Dragon
Knight but no one heard woman swarmed
over her like weasels pinching her lakes
and kicking her in the belly and someone
hit her in the face and she felt her
teeth shatter then she saw the bright
glimmer of Steel the knife plunged into
her belly and tour and tour and tour
until there was nothing left of her down
there but shiny wet ribbons okay now on
songs who woke up from this nightmare
this is when she had her first period
she noticed her thighs were sticky and
there was blood on the blankets but
let's take a closer look at this dream
and exactly how George worded some of
this text the first sentence says the
mob surged around her shrieking a
maddening beast with a thousand faces I
don't know about you but when I think of
a thousand faces I immediately think of
the faceless men which we all know that
is what Aria eventually tried to become
a faceless man the second sentence hints
at this - it says everywhere she turned
she saw faces twisted into monstrous
inhuman masks the faces at the house of
black and white can be interpreted as
masks also in my opinion let's look at
some of the other sentences from the
dream though
it also says she wept and told them she
had never done them hurt yet they
dragged her from her horse all the same
no she cried no please don't don't but
no one paid her
any heed that line kind of stuck out to
me too it says no one paid her any heed
and no one is also another reference to
the faceless men when salsa was being
attacked in this dream it says she
shouted for sir Dantas for her brother's
her dead father and even her wolf but
why didn't she scream for Arya she
screamed for her other family members to
help her but there was no mention of
Arya
maybe that is symbolic and it's because
Arya is actually gonna be the one who
attacks her I don't know about you but I
find being attacked and I'm screaming
for my family to help me I would scream
for all of them I would definitely ask
for arias help before I would ask for my
dead father's help knowing he can't do
anything to help me but let's move on to
the next sentence of the dream this one
is very interesting in my opinion it
says woman swarmed over her like weasels
pinching her legs and kicking her in the
belly and someone hit her in the face
and she felt her teeth shatter okay so
it says woman swarmed over her like
weasels so now we know whoever this is
that is attacking her is a female
because it does say woman but what's
even more interesting than that is the
fact that it says woman swarmed over her
like weasels
now the word weasel might not mean
anything to some of you but at the time
of this dream in this book
aurilla is actually at Harrenhal at the
time as Roose Bolton's cup bearer but no
one knows it's Arya because she's using
different names at the time and can you
guess what one of those names is she
often uses the name weasel in her and
Jack and AG are used weasel soup as they
killed some of the guards at Harrenhal
in order to free some of the prisoners
in the cells Arya has a direct
connection to the word weasel because
it's one of her nicknames to conceal her
identity which is exactly what Songza is
dreaming about maybe I'm crazy but I
think there could be something there but
let's move on there is something else I
want to point out that happened in the
third book a Storm of Swords and one of
arias chapters while she is with the
Hound while Arya and the Hound are
together they end up having a
conversation in the Hound a Soria if she
has ever had a brother she wanted to
kill then he laughs and he says or maybe
a sister then it says the Hound must
have seen something in her face
because he leans in closer and he says
Shawn's up that's it isn't it
the wolf [ __ ] wants to kill the pretty
bird when the Hound says wolf [ __ ] he
is referring to Oreo and when he says
the pretty little bird he is referring
to Psalms up because that's what he
always calls her that definitely
intrigues me because what could the
Hound have possibly seen in aurea's face
that would make him think Oreo wants to
kill her sister songs oh did he just
notice a resemblance between the two
sisters or did he see something more
sinister in Orias face something lying
underneath that only another killer
could see I don't know but you tell me I
think there is some evidence that points
to hurry up possibly killing Sansa that
doesn't mean it will happen but there
are some hints that say it could happen
but it's all open for interpretation and
I just wanted to present a few things to
you then you can be the judge there is
also one other thing he should keep in
mind a few years ago George RR Martin's
original outline for this story leaked
online back in 1993 George RR Martin's
set out an outline in hopes of getting
these books published and in those three
pages he listed some of the key things
he wanted to happen over the course of
his story but most importantly he listed
the five main characters he said would
survive the entire story and those five
characters were Daenerys Targaryen
Tyrion Lannister Jon Snow bran stark and
Arya Stark guess who did not make the
list Shaun's a stark George RR Martin's
original outline did not have Sansa
Stark surviving his story but he did not
say how she would die but hey who knows
maybe his original plan for who would
live or die has changed but then again
maybe it hasn't he did change some of
the storylines but what he change who
his key characters were I don't know
probably not but that's for you to
decide let me know what you think like I
said at the beginning of the video I
don't know if songs a will die or not
but I think it's worth discussing either
way thank you very much for watching the
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
who continues to support this channel
have a great day I will see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]